ABC News and Time magazine go full
mainstream media and you should never go
full mainstream media as president Trump
forces Democrats hand on the contrived
non traversée at the border which I told
you might happen yesterday when this
news broke we'll get to that then the
Supreme Court raises our taxes but
foreshadows a possible huge victory for
American liberty we'll get into that
finally the mailbag I'm Michael Knowles
and this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
I also want to address something that I
put on Twitter yesterday I was citing a
Pat Robertson quote about how feminism
causes women to kill their children and
practice witchcraft and become lesbians
and all that and I use that to refer to
soccer this has gone internationally
viral I have Tory members of parliament
in the UK tweeting about it all these
soccer journalists around the world we
will get to that because it really
brought up a few interesting points
before we do Dollar Shave Club I got to
talk if you want silky soft skin such as
I have then you gotta use Dollar Shave
Club baby Dollar Shave Club is so good
and it is it is my favorite razor I've
ever used and I'm I wasn't really a
cheapo on razors I'd have those cheap
bows for travel but I always actually
spent money on pretty nice razors and
this is the best one by far I love it I
use it all the time
Dollar Shave delivers everything you
need to look feel and smell your best it
has everything you need to get ready in
the bathroom now it has a lot of
products it's not just the razor it
started out it was just the razor now
they have dr. Carver's shave butter
which is good I usually shave dry so
just get out of the shower and just go
with the razor but dr. Carver's shea
butter changed that it's not that giant
foamy yucky stuff it's not that little
soy boy gel you know it's the shave
butter it's really really good and it
has everything shampoo conditioner body
wash toothpaste hair gel even a modern
disposable bidet for an advocate can I
call it that these are one wipe Charlies
use your imagination here's a great way
to try a bunch of Dollar Shave club's
products for just 5 bucks you can get
their daily essentials starter set it
comes with body cleanser one wipe
Charlies can't even say without laughing
their world-famous shave butter and
their best razor the six blade executive
which is the best razor I've ever used
keep the blades coming for a few more
bucks a month and add in shampoo
toothpaste anything else you need for
the bathroom check it all out at
dollarshaveclub.com slash cough fa ce
o-- v fa e fe dollarshaveclub.com slash
cough fa it reminds me that six blade
razor of a few years ago hipsters
started shaving with straight blades
because they're just so stupid this is a
good idea let me just use a knife on my
face
not a trained Barbara yeah don't do that
use the six blade executive
dollarshaveclub.com slash Kofi Fang
okay to begin I sent out this tweet
yesterday I know I actually must thank
all of the viewers in the listeners who
like soccer which by my last count is
ninety nine point eight percent of them
because I have been on this holy jihad
against the World Cup because I really
don't like soccer so anyway I decided to
kind of have a little fun with this and
use a pat robertson quote the
televangelists the squinty eyed guy and
substitute soccer for feminism so that
the quote from pat robertson is this the
feminist agenda is not about equal
rights for women it is about a socialist
anti-family political movement that
encourages women to leave their husbands
kill their children practice witchcraft
destroy capitalism and become lesbians
this is I so I've substituted soccer and
nobody got this so I had Conservative
MPs in the UK tweeting all these
international soccer journalists and
nobody caught the reference and I was
really shocked because every
conservatives should know that quote
that is one of the greatest quotes in
the history of the English language and
of politics it is so funny because it
gets it this thing that I think
conservatives should always play around
with which is you say a quote and then
people don't know if you're kidding or
not you know and maybe you're kidding
maybe you're not kidding me you're just
having a little fun with it who knows
but the quote actually got me thinking
because it sounds so crazy and Pat
Robertson certainly says some some
out-there things but but on this quote I
said I wonder if it's true I wonder if
there's any truth to it it sounds so
crazy let's just go through the points
the feminist agenda is not about equal
rights for women obviously it's not it
is so awful and vicious to any woman who
contradicts its orthodoxy Sarah Palin
Sarah Sanders we saw that it's vicious
awful cuts women off at the knees says
that women who don't you know become
middle managers at the widget Factory
women who choose to have children and
raise them that they're like fake women
or something there was a feminist
Journal that said that Sarah Palin is
just pretending to be a woman that she's
not really a woman
so yeah that's obviously true it's
socialist
of course we saw the woman's March after
Donald Trump was elected it was all anti
capitalism we need to raise taxes we
need to you know take over the means of
production I mean it was a very
left-wing economically anti-family
political movement that encourages women
to leave their husbands there's the one
of the most famous quotes and the
feminist movement is from arena done
which is that a woman needs a man like a
fish needs a bicycle certainly that's
the case the most famous feminists play
is a doll house by henrik ibsen where at
the end the woman leaves her family that
this has been he won awards from
feminist organizations for that so that
hard to say no kill their children
america kills a million children a year
a million babies a year in the womb and
we have since roe v-- wade was decided
by the supreme court then it gets a
little kooky and you kind of wonder cuz
then he says it encourages women to
practice witchcraft you know and is that
it is could that possibly be true but
then then i thought about it and the the
modern feminist movement has this
undeniable connection to occult imagery
all the way the whole time it always has
and I said maybe maybe I'm just
imagining this who knows then I said you
know the main feminist music festival
explicitly a feminist music festival
from Sarah McLaughlin in the 90s is
called Lilith Fair and it was all female
performers and there was no men allowed
rent and Lilith Lilith Fair refers to
Lilith a mythical demon who snatches
away babies in the night and kills them
so I that's a little weird I wonder why
they named it after that then I went to
my favorite web site at the greatest
website on the Internet everyday
feminism I said well let's see if there
is this a cult aspect of feminism I bet
I'll find it on every day oh there it is
said I I wonder if they up and there it
is the second that page lines this is
like the third article on everyday
feminism the headline is seven ways to
use spiritual practice to heal and
resist and I'll just read you this is
the first like two paragraphs of this of
this piece yeah you can barely get
through a handful of dried rose petals
and Apple sliced with a spoon piloncillo
and a few drops of sweet-smelling
essential oils stirred into a pot
boiling water this is the recipe to my
mother's love potion made to attract
self-love a physical manifestation of
love to pour over one's body while
reciting positive affirmations she
raised me with tons of Remedios de la
abuela or remedies from Grandma from an
onion on your belly button to relieve a
fever burning a Palo Santo to rid
negative energy to the belief that
loving yourself is a radical act of
resistance all knowledge that was passed
down to her from parents TS ET au s--
and Abuelo's eb subway lows among others
ancestral spirituality is a deeply
personal practice it's a vague term that
essentially boils down to the act of
connecting with one spirit through but
not limited to Brujeria herbalism
astrology Oracle's and much more double
double toil and trouble fire burn and
cauldron bubble
I actually was shocked I did not see
those connections but you know you read
that that's like one of the main
articles on everyday feminism you say oh
I guess feminism does have this bizarre
connection to the occult and then
finally Pat Robertson says feminism
makes women want to become lesbians who
tries to make them into lesbians and
that one also I said that can't possibly
be true and then I read The Washington
Post a couple weeks ago where a Suzanna
Danuta Walter's professor of sociology
director of the women's sexuality Gender
Studies program at Northeastern and
editor of a major Gender Studies journal
called signs wrote a piece called why
can't we hate men you know maybe I think
because Pat Robertson put that quote out
in a fundraising letter in the early 90s
and everyone said he was a total wacko
and crazy and then you know leave it to
feminists to prove him right even if it
wasn't right at the time they say oh
that's a pretty good idea Pat Robertson
maybe we should do it so anyway I want I
want conservatives to know that quote it
is one of the funniest quotes ever
written in politics you should know it
and their recited frequently and see if
your lefty friends heads just explode
when you say moving on to important news
of the day and this has been a banner
day for the mainstream media so you
might you might have seen this chyron
Donald Trump tweeted it out who says the
media are biased who says the mainstream
networks are biased ABC run
Kiron it's a picture of Donald Trump on
the screen and then the chyron says a
Paul Manafort pleads guilty to five
charges of manslaughter Paul Manafort
who is the head of the Trump campaign
for like five minutes
during around the convention he was
brought on to the campaign to help get
delegates at the Republican convention
and he's a longtime lobbyist and you
know it seems like they've got him the
Muller investigation has him on maybe
some money laundering maybe obstructing
justice whatever they ship him off to
jail
thank goodness finally our streets are
safe with Paul man afford a
seventy-year-old lobbyist is in the
clink thank goodness and so they put him
there and then ABC ups his charges to
five counts of manslaughter eventually
they apologize they issue something they
say we regret and apologize for the
false lower graphic we're investigating
how this happened why was allowed on air
we apologize I know why was allowed on
air because these crazy lefties working
in your newsroom put it up there they
let it happen that's why very very
strange but not to be outdone Time
magazine posted its new cover and its
new cover is an imposing figure of
Donald Trump staring down at a crying
cute little illegal alien baby or
toddler and it says welcome to America
mmm Trump is like the Wold himself right
and this is not the first time that Time
magazine has done this Time magazine is
running zillion covers against Donald
Trump
they had one where he's looking into the
mirror and it's a picture of him as king
and it says King me and this is
unbelievable by the way Donald Trump is
the least authoritarian president in my
lifetime this guy is constantly saying
can't do it the law says this I don't
want it I'm just following the law I
can't be an imperial president I'm not
gonna make this decision unilaterally
I'm not gonna force nuns to pay for
abortions or contraception I'm not going
to force this group to do this I'm not
going to force this group to do that and
they call him an authoritarian because
up is down in Wars peace they have
another one where it's Donald Trump and
it's his screaming face on fire or fire
in the background right that's Trump
because he's supposed to be furious and
chaotic not at all he was one of the
least emotional presence I've also seen
in my lifetime
sees the Teflon Don that's his that's
his new Nick
from John Gotti then there's another one
that they had it was Donald Trump and
the Washington Monument was crumbling
because the country is crumbling under
Donald Trump except that unemployment is
at virtually all-time lows and
disability claims are way down which
means the Social Security Administration
might be able to last more into the
future and we have a pretty booming
economy and the IMF says that it's
Trump's responsibility for that booming
economy and we've finally taking a
serious line on or trade deals and our
foreign affairs are looking pretty good
we've got North Korea coming to the
table possibly to denuclearize if other
than everything going great
Washington is crumbling and and then
finally they have this the meltdown one
this is the Trump meltdown it's come ins
face was melting
there's no meltdown and this gets to a
point we're going to talk about later
this executive order that Donald Trump
issued about the immigration separation
at the border this actually may have
worked out all right I said yesterday in
the ad in the show when this news broke
I said it seems bad but we've got to
read and see see what happened because
it seems bad on the surface but maybe
who knows who knows how it actually
looks we'll get to that too because
there isn't a meltdown
then in moving from the world of news
media to Hollywood media you have Peter
Fonda former actor Peter Fonda the
brother of that traitor Jane Fonda he
goes out and he starts tweeting and says
that we need to rip Baron Trump from his
mother's arms and throw him into a cage
with pedophiles see what happens then he
called for riots in the streets called
for 90 million people to come out you
know start targeting politicians
children and you you saw this kind of
radical call-to-action from Tom Arnold
to Tom Arnold didn't say any of the
horrible things that Peter Fonda said it
was that same come on you got to do
something you've got to come on
everything's terrible you got to do
something except all of the things that
they're all screaming about now we're
happening under Barack Obama's
administration in much worse ways one
thing about this news story that it like
the the bright side of this news story
the silver lining is that every single
day more terrible stories from the Obama
administration come out that make Donald
Trump look like a boy scout
this is according to the AP out of today
according to a federal court filing
fourteen-year-old kids under the Obama
administration 14 year old illegal
aliens were exposed to long periods of
solitary confinement they were found
shivering nude on the concrete floor of
jail cells
according to witnesses at some of these
holding facilities these kids would show
up with bruises broken bones which were
blamed on the guards under Barack Obama
here's some testimony this is from one
of the kids under Barack Obama I don't
know if I made that clear enough
whenever they used to restrain me and
put me in the chair they would handcuff
me strapped me down all the way from
your feet all the way to your chest you
couldn't really move they have total
control over you they also put a bag
over your head that has little holes you
can see through it but you feel
suffocated with the bag on what year did
that come from 2018 wrong 2017 wrong
2015 that's when that happened there was
an ACLU report just in May there was
widespread abuse of illegal aliens from
2009 to 2014 all under Obama in the
mainstream media didn't say boo they
didn't say peep because they don't
actually care about this whatsoever it
is just the only cudgel that they can
contrive and make up to attack Donald
Trump because everything else is going
so well so let's talk about this
executive order we got a little bit of
time before the mailbag this executive
order came out yesterday during this
show and he said okay we're gonna stop
separating these families we got to
figure out a way to stop separating the
families and keep them detained together
until we can figure out their
immigration situation either prosecute
or file for asylum or deport them so we
know all of the outrageous fake right we
know we've just demonstrated that so my
thought initially is why would dumb
trump cave on this this is a winner of
an issue we'll get to the numbers on it
in a second why would Donald Trump cave
why would he cave first you have to find
out what the executive order says as I
mentioned because that you know the the
Devils in the detail so let's see what
it says it says that the Health and
Human Services Secretary Kirsten Nielsen
will have custody of families during
criminal proceedings and asylum
adjudication so instead of putting the
parent
with the US Marshals and the kids with
Health and Human Services this executive
order says Health and Human Services
oh I'm sorry a Department of Homeland
Security is is going to have custody of
these families during criminal
proceedings but the question is which is
it is are these is this criminal
detention or is this some kind of
government program welfare program to
detain people who have nowhere else to
go
which is it because in the law says you
can't put the kids in jail and if you
let the parents go and you don't keep
them held in custody then they'll just
go and they won't show up to their
asylum hearings or their their criminal
hearings so then the executive order
tells Secretary of Defense mattis to
construct facilities or use existing
facilities to house them - so now we've
got multiple agencies federal agencies
coming in here to talk about where we're
going to house them and then the order
urges Attorney General Jeff Sessions to
prioritize all of these proceedings so
that the Florez consent decree which
says that the kids can't be in jail for
more than 20 days that might not even
matter if we can get all of this taken
care of within 20 days the the bill that
Ted Cruz proposed would have done the
same thing would say let's take care of
this within 14 days then you don't need
to worry about Flores okay let's see if
that happens you know actually that that
last part concerning Jeff Sessions is a
lot of the good stuff from Ted Cruz's
bill is just in this executive order but
can it go through we know from public
polling that this is what most people
want almost the majority of Americans
mid-40s 44 percent or so 42% say that
they want the families to be detained
together but not released detained
together if they and then we kick him
out of the country because it's a crime
to come into this country so also in the
executive order when Donald Trump was
announcing it he said where well it's
consistent with the law and where
appropriate we will enforce these things
but that isn't consistent with the law
you can't jail the kids and you can't
let the parents go you you they've
committed a crime you can't just let
them into the country you have borders
or you don't have a country so on the
one hand this may mean that the
executive order does nothing right we're
consistent with the law and when
appropriate which is the zero percent of
the
I might do nothing but the the thing
that it did do and I witnessed this
myself on Kamala Harris is Twitter
account is it forced Democrats hand it
forced them to show what they really
think about immigration and when it
comes to Kamala Harris it was hilarious
the way that it happened so Kamala
Harris tweets out at the I think it was
11:15 11:15 in the morning Pacific time
she tweets that this administration must
end the zero-tolerance policy which has
created this crisis it can be reversed
by the president right now so then
Donald Trump said okay okay that's fine
there's the executive order that we're
not gonna separate them anymore there
you go that's what you get so then right
after he does that we're talking not
even four hours later after she said
that first week she goes this executive
order doesn't fix the crisis
indefinitely detaining children with
their families in camps is inhumane and
will not make us safe what what do you
you just did you read your Twitter
account from four hours ago when you
said we need to keep the families
together keep the families together
separating the families is inhumane then
four hours later she says keeping the
families together is inhumane so what
what do you do you want to go back to
the other one
cuz we can that's fine that's why we
just rip up the executive order go back
to the but something tells me something
tells me that even if we did that then
she would she would just go back and say
separating families is inhumane because
what do they want they want open borders
that's all they want why do they want to
open borders because every day we arrest
a thousand people crossing the border
illegally who knows how many are coming
over we know that those illegal aliens
are more likely to identify with the
Democrat Party by several multiples and
we know that even after staying in the
country for a long time or the children
of immigrants and the grandchildren of
immigrants are very very likely to vote
for Democrats between three and eight
point seven five times more likely to
vote for Democrats than for Republicans
so what the Democrats want is to open up
those borders flood the country with
illegal aliens so that at least one or
two generations in the future they're
importing their own voters and they'll
make the Republicans electorally
extinct though that's just what the
social science data
so Trump force their hand right because
she looks ridiculous she she made
herself a laughingstock she said I
demand this he said fine I'll call your
bluff I'll give it to you she says oh I
don't really want that right you don't
want that because you want to open
borders this is why the executive word
seems bad but really it could be a big
win especially if it doesn't actually
affect policy which it certainly cannot
because what it actually instructs the
government to do is illegal so it camp
it can't really do that but this is why
it might turn out great illegal
immigration is a huge loser for
Democrats it is a big big loser with a
capital L 19 percent according to a
YouGov poll that just came out only 19
percent of Americans favor catch and
release 81% of Americans despised the
policy of catch and release which was
our prior immigration policy we catch
these people and say oh well we can't
separate in this and that's okay you
just go but you better show up to your
hearing right not even a chance they're
gonna show up to their hearing the
numbers get more interesting because 70
percent of Democrats oppose catch and
release of Democrats 67 percent of
Hillary voters oppose catch and release
64% of self-described liberals of left
wingers of the left part of the
Democratic Party which is now the whole
Democratic Party oppose catch and
release the vast majority of voters
across virtually every demographic
oppose open borders and catch and
release it's a big winner for Trump and
for Republicans on this issue and if he
can force their hands and make them
state out in the open where for catch
and release were up in borders just like
he made Kamala Harris do that's a big
electoral winner I think the Democrats
thought that this issue if they could
contrive this fake crisis at the border
which has really been going on under
Obama and they were silent the whole
time if they could contrive that before
the midterms that they would have
finally get any momentum going into the
midterms and then Donald Trump basically
flipped it right back on them really
good strategic mr. president even by the
way if you look further down the line to
Donald Trump's bass independence 83%
oppose catch-and-release moderates 84%
of post catch-and-release GOP 93% of
post catch
release among self-described
conservatives 93% of post
catch-and-release and of Trump voters 96
percent oppose catch-and-release
so it doesn't look like as we feared
with that executive order it doesn't
look like we're reverting to that
anytime soon he couldn't because
statistically Trump's entire voting base
opposes the policy very very good before
we get to the mailbag I do want to talk
about this Supreme Court ruling there
was a Supreme Court ruling came out
today from the the cases quill
corporation versus North Dakota and the
question was on whether internet sites
have to collect state taxes can states
demand that internet sites collect state
taxes even if they're out of state right
that's one way that internet shopping is
so much better is you can skirt a lot of
taxes the decision is pretty interesting
some conservatives are angry about the
decision which will raise our taxes
because it will allow companies to force
companies to start charging state taxes
on the products that we buy online but
some conservatives are complaining cuz
the taxes go up but that's actually a
conservative decision which is why it
was 5-4 and it broke down Kennedy who's
a little bit of a squish Ginsburg the
big lefty and then to staunch
conservatives Alito and Gorsuch and and
Thomas I'm sorry 305 so three of the the
actual conservatives on the court
Alito Gorsuch and Thomas who's probably
the most original list they were all in
favor of this ruling and Roberts Breyer
Sotomayor and Kagan Roberts being asked
wish Breyer being a lefty Sotomayor and
insane lefty and Kagan a fairly smart
still very left-wing woman were all
opposed to it so the old precedent would
protect these out-of-state sellers from
being required to collect taxes Gorsuch
referred to this in the past as a
judicially created tax shelter and the
the thing we should take away from this
case is not that it's a good thing that
we're gonna have to pay more money to
buy stuff that's very frustrating I
don't like that at all
but what we should take away is the
health of the judicial philosophy of the
conservatives on the court originalism
or textualism saying that the law means
what the law means that the words really
have meaning and they don't just
magically change over time the
Constitution isn't a living breathing
document that sprouts legs and starts
dancing on the desk right it's a dead
piece of paper with words written on it
that have meaning because Justice Scalia
said this to me I had the privilege of
medium a couple times before he died and
he said that the the health of that
philosophy is that if you're a good
judge you won't always like your
decision if you always like the decision
that you come to then you're probably
not following the law and following the
Constitution but if you don't if
sometimes you're very upset with the
decision you come to but that's where
the logic of the law has led that means
you're probably a pretty good judge and
that's what happened with conservatives
today so I think it's a broadly a win
even though it's gonna cost us money sad
let's get to the good news the good news
on this decision is regarding Chevron
deference
so Chevron deference is this principle
that on matters of interpreting statutes
the courts should defer to the
administrative agencies who are to whom
the statutes apply so it's it's the it's
because the administrative state the
deep state you know the federal agencies
have gotten so out of control ur so many
statutes that the courts have basically
outsourced the interpretation of those
statutes to the administrative agencies
this is obviously anti-constitutional
this is a really bad thing in that same
time I got to meet Scalia he said the
great threat to American liberty was the
administrative state this bloated
administrative state and Justice Kennedy
just wrote quote it seems necessary and
appropriate to reconsider in an
appropriate case the premises that
underlie Chevron and how courts have
implemented that decision and Kennedy
you know Kennedy's the swing vote on the
court but he's joined on two opinions
that have talked about this before like
Roberts's Arlington versus FCC dissent
he cites Thomas and also Alito judge
Alito who is then on the tenth circuit
when it comes to Chevron that this could
be a monumental win for American liberty
if the courts stop deferring to
administrative agencies when they should
when those questions should be left to
courts
would totally upended Minister ativ law
and would be a big big win America ain't
over yet this is still a chance that we
can survive ok I want to get to the mail
but maybe I'll do one mailbag question
just to give you a little taste and then
we'll have to say goodbye to Facebook
and YouTube and get to the rest of the
mailbag from Andrew Mike I just finished
listening to EPP 171 what happens when
conservatives begin to feel the same way
as the left and they're useful idiots as
in they would prefer to punish their
ideological opposites rather than win
them over I'm almost there but don't
really want to be unlike their
experience producing good policies
leftists are pretty good at inviting
their opponents to join them in the mud
sometimes I feel like we should give
them the terrible treatment pretend to
endure you spoke about this issue with
your guest the idea that we're
comfortable and can't stand it or have
lost perspective I do feel that a brief
rash of face-punching
would reconvince us all that talking is
a very nice alternative
please exclude my last name if you
address this comment Thanks my commute
is consumed by the daily wire podcast
sincerely John Smith no I'm kidding
that's not his name I don't even
remember what the name was that is a
great question so you you seem to have
been on Twitter too much that's what
happens this house because the lefties
do just want to cuddle us they totally
want to just knock us over the head and
you know smack us on this question so
they'll they'll say we don't want a
debate we don't want to argue we don't
want to talk to you
we're just gonna shut you up and no
speech and heckle you and what hecklers
veto right if you my rule on this is if
you're on Twitter and you genuinely get
angry that is you doing it wrong
you're doing it wrong don't do it like
let it let it go do not punch them in
the face as much as you might want to it
the way that you can convince people is
by laughing at them I think you're not
know but the left is not doing itself
any favors right now by screaming and
whining it no you know and all that they
aren't I mean they're losing everything
they're losing all of the ground they'd
made on the culture were even they're
losing their political
around me they aren't winning elections
they haven't been winning elections
since 2008 really so keep up what we're
doing laugh at them expose how crazy
their arguments are and treat them like
children you wouldn't punch a child in
the face and they are behaving like
little children you've just got to take
a firm stand don't let them get away
with everything you know but you want
them to get better you want them to kind
of see how crazy their their mania has
made them and and so that's alright next
question from Henry Michael what do you
think is a good response when people say
that gender and sex are different or
disconnected this is what I think
absolutely proved over and over again we
actually add that's it this is just
wrong
it's just ridiculous it's no it's a way
that the left has tried to make you
ignore the obvious reality that is right
in front of you one of the essential
realities of human nature which is the
complementarity of men and women that
sexual difference between men and women
they just want you to ignore that so
they say no no that's that that's sex
but but sex too is different 6 what we
mean 6 - yeah no it's like it's like sex
but it's it's different but no it isn't
at all gender refers to grammar there
are gendered nouns so in I don't know in
Italian the word for soccer kal Cho is
masculine it ends in an O it takes the
masculine articles even though it's
obviously a very effeminate sport if
those are different the writer that's
just a grammatical construction they
apply that to human beings because they
want to pretend that sex isn't a real
thing but yeah nobody's getting fooled
by that we've got a lot more mailbag to
get to before we do that I'm sorry if
you're on Facebook or YouTube gotta say
goodbye you got to go to daily wired.com
daily wire.com you get me with the
Andrew Klavan sure you get the Ben
Shapiro show all of that for $10 a month
$100 for an annual membership none of
that matters this is what matters they
left just tears tumblr they're pouring
out right now ABC News is so angry
they're they're accusing Paul Manafort
of five counts of manslaughter not one
not three five counts of manslaughter
you're gonna want to have this otherwise
you're gonna drown go to daily wire calm
we'll be right back
from NOAA the bigotry of low
expectations I've heard this before but
I don't know what it means can you give
us an example and how does this affect a
community at large also did I use effect
correctly or should it be the other one
with the e effect or effect I know you
used it correctly effect is the verb
when you are going to effect something
effect is the noun the effect of
something that you have affected but
effect can also be the condescending
tone that I'm putting on right now which
is also a noun it's a little confusing
but you can hopefully keep it together
the soft bigotry of low expectations is
a phrase coined during the Bush era and
it refers to that that really nice
bigotry you know when basically people
suggest that if you're the Liberals do
this all the time especially when it
comes to education they suggest that you
know minority students people from
ethnic minorities or poor communities
they couldn't possibly be as successful
or as smart or as educated as all those
rich white people over there so they say
lower the standards let's just maybe we
should lower the standards for them
because oh good you've got a D oh good
that's because you're because of your
skin color you could never get an A so
oh good good good and it's just awful
it's so insidious because it's
pretending to be nice but it's really
really wicked you know it's not the
conservative stance broadly is to treat
people like they're people like they
have dignity and self-respect or at
least they should and they should do it
for themselves but the soft bigotry of
low expectations oh those minority
people they can they could never work
they could never be success give them
handouts let's just isnt matts better
for that's nice
aren't at night and don't forget to vote
for me isn't this aren't I nice I'm a
good person or yet this don't but don't
forget to vote that's the soft bigotry
of low expectations it's really really
awful and one of the one of the great
phrases from the Bush administration to
identify it next question from mark dear
reincarnation of Liam Neeson in gangs of
New York I've never gotten that one
before
that is it totally new and whoever came
up with that I will find you and I will
kill you first
thank you for your best man speech
advice a few weeks ago I ended up giving
the best speech I'm glad that worked out
I'm that was a there was a week or two
probably three weeks ago at this point I
want to know what has happened to art
how did we go from Botticelli Tolstoy
and Chopin to the muck we have now how
is it that the most popular art of the
age has gone from something that could
be described as being touched by the
divine
- Beyonce mumble rapping expletives all
the best mark World War one that's the
answer
World War one also the triumph of
individualism in Western culture which
is sort of tied to that but it had been
building since the Renaissance urger
since the 16th century even before that
World War one is the answer it's when
Europe just destroyed itself Yeats
William Butler Yeats the last of the
great poets wrote about this in the poem
the second coming turning and turning in
the widening gyre the Falcon cannot hear
the falconer you know anarchy is loosed
upon the world what rough beast is this
slouching toward Bethlehem to be born
the chaos that occurred after World War
two I believe he wrote that in 1919 part
of the issue here is that everything had
been done there was this total breakdown
after the world war where everything had
been done every all of the great
beginning in the sixteenth century or
really before that all the way through
the modern era to the - World War one
everything had been done and then Europe
destroyed itself and everything was in
rubble and everything was dead and awful
it had run out it had run out of steam
and so the artists at this era there may
in 1914 there were some new things that
were happening they were beginning to
start World War two ended that it
radically changed the world and it ended
Europe and so artists responded to that
in three ways they started mocking the
old Beauty sort of parody or satire of
the old beautiful things they started
deconstructing it down to its foundation
you see a lot of fundamentalism come up
in this period artistic fundamentalism
and then you had destruction not just
deconstruction but destruction
destructing the idea of art itself
Hemingway had I by the way I can't claim
originality on those points Jacques
bores and writes about that beautifully
and from dawn to decadence Ernest
Hemingway
had a line about this at the time I
think he wrote this in 1925 the age
demanded that we sing and cut away our
tongue the age demanded that we flow and
hammered in the bum the age demanded
that we danced and jammed us into iron
pants and in the end the age was handed
the sort of stuff
that it demanded and that sums it up he
Hemingway was a he was so much a icon of
that period of time that really began
this decay and he he was produced by it
you know he had gone through this
experience of the First World War
and it changed everything and where you
see the breakdown of like Beyonce and
and mumble mumbling all these expletive
filled rap lyrics I forgot to mention
her in that feminism bit because she did
they all goddess Beyonce and the divine
goddess okay
hey consider that too but how do we get
to that because there was this movement
called Dadaism which really sums it all
up all of those things that the artists
did to react to world war one and the
death of their culture come up in
Dadaism from Dada
number three quote I don't even want to
know that any man lived before me and
that's what they're saying Dada this
this artistic this anti artistic
movement the word comes from the French
for baby talk Dada
there's this obsessive mischievous
quality to it it's like the old joke how
many surrealist poets does it take to
screw in a light bulb fish that's art
that's what art had become right you've
gone from Botticelli to to this madness
in this breakdown and the premise of it
the premise of all of this is that
society is mad how else could you go
through the experience of World War one
without concluding that society is mad
that some random terrorist in Serbia
shoots the Archduke Franz Ferdinand and
this launches a series of events that
led for German militarism to try to take
over the continent and you get mired
down in the stalemate this Western Front
for four years of just Europe ripping
each other to shreds just blood and guts
and mayhem pouring out of the continent
how of this king talking to this king
and you know the Kaiser would write to
Tsar Nicholas and say dear Nicky isn't
this so strange you know you'd have to
conclude that the society is mad this
comes in the wake also of Nietzsche who
says God is dead that the belief in the
in the spiritual elements that have
animated Western culture all breaks down
no sense no logic no communication and
that defines our art today there's no
sense to it it's all just babble it's
all babble and it's all neo Dada that's
what we're just getting the the artistic
children of the Dada movement and so I
you might have been hoping that I could
say well don't worry we're going to get
Chopin back any time now
oh yeah box should be coming around
pretty soon I don't see it there well
you know the Holy Spirit animates a
society at various points in history you
see it how on earth did after you know
ages of total artistic death did Dante
come out how did how do these people
will just pop up how do the parts of
spiritual and cultural renewal come out
of nowhere well you know it just it
these things can happen but you got to
go through a lot of darkness since then
and you can't really predict when it's
going to happen so don't hold your
breath waiting for Bach he's not coming
back soon my friend sorry to say let's
get one or two more before we have to go
from Spencer o Hawaiian Buccaneer of
Sicilian descent Knowles you rightly
described many leftists and even some
conservatives as being lightly educated
gotta love that phrase but in a time
when interest in the past seems to be at
an all-time low and means for instant
gratification exist everywhere in
abundance
how and why should people go about
making themselves more than just lightly
educated would you prescribe a specific
curriculum of essential books to read if
so what are the some of the books that
you would include in it Spencer PS today
is my birthday happy birthday except you
probably wrote that a few days ago so
it's not your birthday anymore sorry
yeah the lightly educated phrase is is
as much a self indictment as it is
entitlement of all of culture because
it's not just that certain people are
stupid and don't read it's that our
education system has utterly failed it
has been utterly hollowed
and so even if you go to a great school
I went to a great high school I went to
a great college you know brand name and
all but they've been hollowed out they
aren't what they used to be
Donald cake and the great ancient Greek
historian former Dean of Yale College
said this was decades ago he said you
can still get an education at Yale but
you don't have to to graduate and then a
few years later he said I'm not even
sure if you can anymore and that's at
the elite universities so this is a I
don't mean to say you know I'm so smart
and you're so stupid that certainly
isn't the case our culture is in the
midst of just a period of total
ignorance and uncultured so what you
have to do is go right back to that can
and go right back to the essentials and
you should but you know I think I think
all of these shows reference Aristotle
like every single day so you should go
right back there to Aristotle and Plato
and you should read up through the Canon
and maybe you know just make some time
for that the reason to do it because
there's instant gratification everywhere
so you know you I don't know you could
probably just eat like giant tubs of ice
cream and watch internet porn and get a
massage all day long we could do that
where we're at that point in culture
where you could certainly do it but your
life will be better you'll be more of a
person you'll be more conscious you'll
be more connected to both the society
around you your past your history and
God if you put throw yourself wholly
into culture and into reading and
knowing about your history it's very
important and a lot of the political
problems were in our cultural problems
and their cultural problems because
we're just so ignorant and uncultured so
you can help fix that problem
start reading pal last question before
we got to go from Jennifer oh this is a
really hard question hi Michael
I'm a Catholic college survivor of rape
and was given Plan B at the hospital to
prevent pregnancy the night after is
this considered abortion or a sin thanks
Jennifer
man I am so sorry to hear that
I'm so sorry you went through that I
hope you're doing well
recovering psychologically and
spiritually from that that's the worst
thing that can happen it's in in many
ways it's worse than murder to happen to
you because
it's it's such a conscious robbing of
your liberty it's so it's so cuts to the
core of what it means to be a human so
I'm really sorry about that as for the
question you asked so I'll give me the
answer as best as we have it is Plan B
the emergency contraceptive / possible
abortive fashioned drug is that abortion
or is that a sin the short answer is we
don't know you're a Catholic student so
I'll give you the church's perspective
the church has not declared definitively
one way or the other on this because we
don't know the plan be drug which is
different than some other of these drugs
primarily exists to prevent ovulation
so exists to prevent the egg and the
sperm from joining together now there
are two different definitions of
abortion here the Catholic definition of
abortion is intentionally you know
killing a fertilized egg and the the
government sort of secular definition of
abortion is preventing the implantation
of a fertilized egg so the Catholic
Church says that life begins at
conception when the egg and the sperm
were joined together the government says
that abort of life begins at
implantation so the sperm and the egg
joined together and they are then
implanted in the uterine wall and goes
on from there we really don't know there
was one study that came out that said
that Plan B does not really work to
prevent implantation that its primary
purpose and its primary function is to
prevent those two from joining if they
don't join then certainly it's not
abortion and and there's there's really
no way of knowing what happened in that
particular case other than maybe
statistically over time whatever I would
say the thing for you to worry about
right now is how to recover
psychologically and spiritually from
what happened to you you should not you
should not right now be worrying about
the statistical probability that the
sperm and the egg were joined but didn't
implant rather than not joining at all
this probably isn't the time for that
maybe you can come to think about that
later maybe science will shed a light on
that later maybe the church will discuss
it in more definitive terms later but
what you should do is figure out how to
put your life back in order after such a
horrific event
and I'll be praying for you and I hope
that that it turns out okay for you okay
that's our show that's a really tough
one to end on I hope you all survived
the weekend you know it is the Clavin
last weekend that affects all of us it's
not just cuz you're listening to this
show doesn't mean the Clavin last
weekend can't affect you so go over by
the way we're about to start work again
on another kingdom I know Drew's talked
about that on his show he has basically
started to finish that that draft so we
could get a season two at some point in
the next 50 or 70 years so you should
catch up on season one listen to that
you can get that another kingdom by
Andrew Clavin is wherever wherever fine
narrative fiction podcasts are
downloaded until then until Monday
I am Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Noel's show I'll see you soon
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jessa alvera the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you